So I won an Emmy.
Here's what that day looked like.
I landed in New York two and a half hours
before the Emmys started, and I was filthy
because I had been hiking and reporting on
a story in Switzerland for two weeks and I
hadn't showered.
I also didn't have any clothes for the Emmys.
So first stop was H&M to grab something to
wear.
I snagged a bunch of clothes, most of it off
the sales rack, and headed to my hotel where
I had about 45 minutes to shower and get ready
before heading to the Emmys.
And then I had a random thought about bacteria
living on my body...
Because I follow John Green on the Internet,
I know that there are trillions of microorganisms
in my body at all time, regardless of how
much soap I use.
Here I am all ready to go.
I hopped on a city bike and booked it just
in time to get to the Emmys.
I did the red carpet thing.
I pretended I was fancy or something, but
I was not expecting to win until...
”Blue States, You're the Problem.”
The New York Times Opinion Video.
The New York Times.
[ANNOUNCER]: Accepting the Emmy: Johnny Harris.
And then I got on stage and gave a little
speech.
So, yeah, that's how I got this big, shiny
trophy and I’m feeling kind of proud about
it.